hi i'm lenny lipton this is my dog belle
lenny lipton is sitting in his living
room
puff
the magic dragon reading something
you've probably heard lived by the sea
and frolicked in the autumn mist in a
land called honolee
lenny wrote what has become the stoner's
anthem i wrote puff the magic dragon
when he was a 19 year old college
student i was a freshman at cornell dal
can you sit
thank you dear
okay i was reading a poem by ogden nash
called custard the dragon soon after he
went to meet friends for dinner as i was
walking down the hill this to the
apartment i was thinking about the poem
i read and i thought i'd try to write
one too about a dragon he got to his
friend's apartment and let himself in i
saw a typewriter on the kitchen table
and i typed puff the magic dragon lived
by the sea and frolicked in the autumn
missed the line called honolee
and although i didn't find out about
this for a couple years peter yarrow who
became the peter of peter paul and mary
is one of the guys who lives in the
apartment he saved the poem i completely
forgot about it i even left it in the
typewriter and he said it to music
that's how the song got written and it
changed my life
but lenny's story doesn't stop there
i've got something like 72 patents
i invented the way to project 3d movies
you're likely to see if you go to the
cinemas he also invented those awkward
glasses you have to wear to see them
this is crystallized
this is the first commercial pair
of
3d active
electronic eyewear and everyone from
nasa to james cameron has used that nasa
on mars and cameron underwater lenny's
also a filmmaker he's produced over 25
movies it's a lifetime achievement award
and he's written several books all about
well film and one autobiography but i
don't think it's of interest my wife
read one chapter and she said she didn't
want to read it anymore
okay so a book about his life is not his
magnum opus good thing a song about
drugs is because that's what it's about
right and people want to think it's
about pot
that's fine with me wait it's not not as
far as i'm concerned puffy magic dragon
is not about drugs and who knows who
knows what i was thinking